huawei has released a whole bunch of new
products and we had hands-on with
huawei's all-new matepad pro 2022 so
here's the rundown the huawei matepad
pro 32 comes with the super device
feature we all know that huawei is
expanding their ecosystem and super
device connectivity allows for easy
transferring of data and documents
between huawei devices like this and
it's super seamless you can even search
for files from different huawei devices
and plunk it into the one you're using
which is pretty handy for those times
you can't remember the location of your
documents they now have a detachable
spot magnetic keyboard and that's always
a welcome upgrade to their peripheral
lineup you can adjust the keyboard for
multiple viewing angles and it goes all
the way to 165 degrees for you artsy and
no dicky fellas out there this makes
your matepad one of the most versatile
devices in your arsenal especially when
it's used together with a stylus the
huawei m pencil has been upgraded to the
second generation here with the aim to
improve workflow efficiency with it you
can easily crop and paste content
convert handwritten notes into text and
navigate between different apps and
windows lastly it's heavenly light at
449 grams and measures 5.9 millimeters
thin
which means you'll barely feel the
weight in your back and arms it weighs
less than 800 grams even with the
keyboard attached so you can pretty much
slot tablet anywhere and carry it around
without much fuss with extreme
portability peripherals that bring your
productivity to the next level and the
super device feature that makes your
life that much easier huawei is coming
in force with a new lineup
do you know that the lack of google
services is still an issue here but the
company has been working hard to
overcome it in recent years which begs
the question
would you get it let us know in the
comment section below and tell us how
you feel about the latest offering to
the tech wool and if you would consider
it let's chat
so i'm here and i'll see you guys soon
take care
man
hopefully i hope they click on our
videos everything's lined up over there
yeah the one on the top is where the
latest video is at and the one at the
bottom where the playlist is at
man i hope they click on them